[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
these are things that i don't even have
the balls to [ __ ] say
because i'm older yeah and i also being
[ __ ] right
can i agree with that
you did you know what i mean my bad
it's like all these asians that are in
entertainment their parents don't want
them to do that let's be honest yeah
like being an actor that's not what your
parents are like hoping you would be
when you grow up so they're renegades as
well
but because you're too rent you're too
much of a renegade they're like oh no
but that's a little too full he shits in
the back of his prius they don't want
that [ __ ] no no that's understandable
i'm okay with that like you should be
shunned by the community
like chinese people just stop [ __ ]
on the street and here you are
an asian sitting in a prius yeah not on
purpose by accident what happened you
didn't even drink i got no hiccups i
know i just have this i i i smoke
cigarettes and i drink a lot of coffee
andrew right i have this certain urgent
i have a certain urge to take a [ __ ]
every once in a while uncontrollably
traffic or like what's the worst
park outside of my dermatologist because
he would rather [ __ ] inside the car than
outside and occur oh my god bro on la
cienega you can't [ __ ] outside of los
angeles it's the busiest street in l.a
yeah so you sit in your prius that [ __ ]
in the prius no
in a bag
yeah yeah
but he has shot in the seat before i
have done that too yeah
so many stories but here's the thing
okay
that
wow what
what why didn't you do you never had a
sudden urge to take a [ __ ] and you had
no control i've shed my pants before
well there we go i don't want a [ __ ] in
my own pants i was sad
oh you're what i'm also tired of was
talking about food jews no i'm saying
well you go like i went to a mexican i'm
not even jewish by the way but you're
not assuming oh yeah oh look at but
anyway um
3.0 do we all look the same yeah you
know what i also like when you're like
in texas and you're in a mexican
restaurant and they go we only use local
ingredients yeah right and it's like
i want guacamole
get the avocado go to vaughn i don't
give a [ __ ]
right
i'm not tired of local ingredients why
are people so proud of that
why are they so proud of the locals or
it's local farmers
here we go and make your farm better and
then
like what are we doing here we joking i
don't support local headphones right
a local cell phone i don't support local
camera like why do we have to support
the local farmer get your [ __ ]
business together get your [ __ ]
business together and then what you'll
do is you'll have something that
everybody wants to buy
very simple yeah i mean i [ __ ] in my
hand the other day for what really would
you do
why yeah for what reason why i don't
know about this one i know i didn't tell
you it was so and then it was the
bathroom was a disaster why did you do
it in your hand though oh god
all right uh yeah you're gonna tell us
i'm going to but i have to there's got
to be an angle okay can i find my angle
yeah
okay [ __ ] you man you white piece of
[ __ ] like that's what we hate about late
night i don't want to see jimmy fallon
like [ __ ] isn't it uncomfortable it
makes me cringe
shut the [ __ ] up why is he so [ __ ]
happy all right just do a depressed
episode go up there be like i'm hungover
i don't feel that good i'm not excited
to meet [ __ ] naomi campbell's niece
or whoever
because we see through it yeah we don't
need it i think he does where the
elevator opens up and he's with paul
mccartney and there's people in the
lobby and then and people go crazy and
the elevator close and they go down yeah
you know what i do i go [ __ ] you well
okay so you grabbed a piece of [ __ ] like
a [ __ ] no like a red ass i cupped the
phone you just i
ah
you know how you kept the fart yeah and
then so what okay so like last night i
was really gassy no remember one fart i
had and you were like what the [ __ ] is
that yeah right i
apologize i'm looking okay good look at
me i apologize it's disgusting
disgusting you cupped a fart in front of
her i always do at night so what i do is
i don't want her to know that i'm
farting okay right so i'll do a cup and
then right no and i'll take my pinky and
my thumb yep and i'll spread the cheeks
open a little bit like this so it comes
out so it comes out with no noise yeah
yep been right done that yeah yeah and
it's my it's my style of doing it yeah
it's great
thank you so much andrew honestly i
completely understand right so i so the
the other night it's respectful it's
like you actually care about her you
don't want bingo
bingo right so i i spread it open and i
cup to fart yep and then when i looked
at my hand in the bed it was a pile of
[ __ ]
oh you didn't feel it at first you just
saw it
yeah oh wow
right but then i felt i felt like you
know my hand went clung yeah you're like
a cartoony clung yeah right yeah i
looked at it
are you okay what's the angle
there is no angle i'm just i'm i'm
telling the straight story
i couldn't find an egg i have an angle
i just [ __ ] in my i couldn't find an
angle
i'm just embarrassed all right
so what it was and then so i had to do
like a um i think i was a waiter right i
was a waiter for years
right so i had to do a
what's the
there is no
there is no way i [ __ ] in my hand is the
angle all right i apologize babe okay
right so like i had to do a waiter thing
yeah most of the world doesn't have
clean water to drink right right and
every night
we pretend to care about those people
out there in the world and then we take
a [ __ ] in clean water
that's so true
yeah
i just pissed in clean drinking water
right there was drinking water that i
peed in
i don't care clearly i don't care right
like i could have scooped it up and sent
it to [ __ ] somebody but i didn't yeah
i took a [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] nobody
cares
we just are a little guilty that we live
in this amazing yeah like is this the
malibu fire
what's behind we just got that installed
today dude this is hysterical
what am i looking at right now is this a
volcano what is it where's that giraffe
dude how many times oh they burned down
and they just replaced them
but you know it's like the [ __ ] what
is the killer whale's name shamu where
they just run it back once
yeah whenever uh i always root for the
animal whenever like
whenever
what the [ __ ] i gotta turn this off
sorry that's so rude it's all good yeah
it's j do plus and
yeah
one of them in the uh
yeah they are outspoken
no i called him anthony boring
yeah yeah yeah because he did that
stupid video with the black and i take
responsibility yeah one
yeah
yeah i trashed him what a [ __ ] cork
so what so i would do that why would you
do that video how stupid are you to do
that video what an idiot would you which
one was it mark or jay [ __ ] idiot
i don't remember i don't even remember i
take responsibility for all the other
guys that are racist
i'll take responsibility for them
you loser yeah dude you met an inuit
i died
the nasty show outside she waited for
you yeah yeah and the only reason i know
she was an inuit is she asked me she was
like is bobby lee coming out and i was
like yeah i think he'll be out in a
second and then she goes okay
i'm an inuit
[Laughter]
i swear to god i swear to god and i go i
hope there's more to this [ __ ] story
and apparently i guess you said
something maybe on the podcast
and she heard that
i remember that i'm did me one she was
there because which the waddling when
she waddled through like an inuit you
can imagine i never had met one until
her and she came out and we both met our
first inuit and she was very and she was
like we support you she like spoke about
the whole community she's like we
support you bobby we just wanted you to
meet one of us and i think you said
something you're like if i meet and then
you would come see me there was
something happening i think i said that
i think i said that and she did go
backstage but i blocked it out i think i
know that's what i had to call out thank
you resurfaced today because now you've
changed
and that's why you spoke about it it all
happens for a reason right and that and
the 12 arm girl
what do you mean would make so much more
non with all the arms
it's like you're really hurting the
community yeah yeah yeah maybe she was
the only one that made that she wasn't
even the goddess it was like listen
[ __ ] you got nothing to do with those
other eight arms
or all this though right or anyone was
thinking if i was her goalkeeper
right fc india right olympic dude
imagine you're doing a [ __ ] free kick
right imagine 19 arms
you'd be like i'm not gonna do it
hey hey uh cristiano you kick it yeah
that's what i say yeah man yeah but i
wouldn't want 19 arms bro no
right yeah why wouldn't you want him
because as a as a dude it's like i feel
like my hands would get jealous
right because which one do you stroke
with bruh oh yeah
and then the one up here yeah the one
that the t-rex one that's up here
that kick it down right
it just blocks your face
right right yeah maybe it's the shame
that's the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
can we learn and grow together i think
that's the most important thing every
time yeah is that a mustache or what is
that i think it's i don't know yeah yeah
yeah
yeah you know you know what it reminds
me of what is that
are you about to make fun of facial hair
[Laughter]
you of all people about to make fun of
facial hair let's go let's have a
whisker zone
like like a tom cruise blow up or do you
ever like really go for it
dude what do you think about his blow up
i respected it
he did it for you
literally like
nobody has a blow up and only positive
[ __ ] ha like but let me just dude we got
to save the turtle
right like who gets angry and doesn't
curse and just has positive things if he
dropped like an n-bomb in the middle of
it i'd be like oh okay this guy really
yeah yeah he just was the best guy
yeah like we got to save people's lives
and their college education i have a
theory that i think that was a pr move
yes but but that's just because i think
that you know his stocks have dropped
since the whole david miscavige thing
and he keeps doing these big action
movies but he's really kind of out of
the oscar contender kind of yeah
so i think i think that was his attempt
to kind of uh galvanize support in the
industry and like make him look like a
good guy like he could because it worked
on me exactly yeah because you really
care about corona i'm immune so i'm like
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but he
he
he used his power and that's when you
know he has power because if i would
have done it this would this is what it
would happen
what happened right hey guys i'm going
to tell you right now and then somebody
would go [ __ ] you and it's the [ __ ]
gopher
[Laughter]
or the guy holding the boom boom [ __ ]
you sit down
[ __ ] right and i'd be like oh i'm
sorry right i thought i was gonna have
this amazing experience i went to that
[ __ ] that horseshit sushi restaurant
the giro dreams of sushi which is dog
[ __ ] it was the worst sushi that had the
empire
dog [ __ ]
absolute dog [ __ ] and let me tell you
something and let me tell you something
i came i spent one thousand dollars
i spent one thousand dollars in in in 25
minutes it was five hundred dollars for
my girl five dollars from me and let me
tell you something i was so i i'm
curious about the cultures i go there to
learn i was so [ __ ] nervous in this
place that i was going to do something
to disrespect them or like being rude by
accident i bought a suit just for this
place
okay just for i have a whole [ __ ]
suit we're there on time i'm screaming
at my girlfriend she's running in heels
because i didn't want to be late because
they said if you're late you could lose
that reservation we are so excited she's
like a big like food enthusiast and we
go in and it was
almost inedible
no really it almost inedible how
heartbreaking i don't know i'm just
waiting
for that that morning we went to the old
we went to the old uh fish market right
they have a new fish market like three
billion dollars that they made and it
was amazing you saw like the tuna
auction it was like it was really sick
and we went to old one to have sushi and
that was the best fish i've ever had in
my entire life that's the thing it was
unbelievable
no it's the wasabi it's you're just if
you just
you're just snorting wasabi that's what
it tastes like when you get there and
you know what they did recently i was so
happy last week they took away his
michelin stars that [ __ ]
wow
holy [ __ ] it's a racket dude you don't
even let japanese people go it's like
you have to be at a fancy hotel to get a
reservation it's the whole [ __ ] is is
nonsense it's a sham it's a sham the
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] let me say
something i knew this about the movie
because if you saw the sushi in eero
yeah you know how like you're as an
actor or you're in documentaries they
put makeup on you yeah they did that
[ __ ] those are the food their food
wasn't even real it's not real in the
food if you look at the food it's glossy
right there's like
sparkles on it almost it glows almost i
just thought that was the quality of the
fish no dude it's hollywood [ __ ]
magic remember how you was like
everything is about the rice yeah dude
i'm not gonna lie the rice was bomb the
rice was born oh the rice but you're
gonna get bomb rice everywhere you go
but let me tell you something let me
also tell you something and i'm in a
room full of asians right now and you
guys will understand this yeah i'm not
spending a thousand dollars on rice
[Laughter]
if that isn't the whitest thing like if
you found out that a white man spent a
thousand dollars on rice
right like like how did they ever
colonize anyone like
i don't even go to asia that's right i
don't go to asian events i know you have
a thing with that what do you mean i
don't know i i noticed that you have a
thing with that yeah yeah
you you're like you know what you're
like what you're like
what this is this is you're not going to
like this thing but like i could take
anything no but you still like it
like
now that now that it's like cool to be
asian oh [ __ ] you're like yo i i paid
the dues like i paved this [ __ ] you know
you're like urkel
you know what i mean like well don't
no but you know like urkel was a black
nerd way before chance the rapper
he was a black nerd when you could not
be a black right he paved the [ __ ]
stones in the street like that's who he
was yeah you're out here being cool
asian dude yeah and then all of a sudden
being cool and asian
is fire and you're like oh no no no
we're not gonna act like i didn't just
do this yeah but is it it but is my
point of view the i think the reason why
um i i refute it and i push it away is
because it's a defense mechanism it's
like you know
i'm happy that asians are killing it but
you're like where was mine no but they
don't invite me to their party
they also don't invite me to the party
nah that's not fair are you sold on like
the other types of restaurants like noma
or
um these other ones that cost like she
wants to go to this one what tell them
about the one in denmark oh you landed
magnus at the airport no it's not magnus
is in norway whatever dude no it's in
denmark it's called noma it's been like
a top rene you have to drive
five hours into the forest
then you have to sleep there in a cabin
oh that's the norway guy that's whatever
that guy is yeah this is i know the
whole i know the whole hustle here yeah
keep going
thank you so much i already know what
happened right now it's also snowing no
of course
of course of course it's not why
wouldn't it be snowing right what else
you have to battle a moose
you know you paid a thousand dollars for
just basically rice you get a 30 course
meal at this place in the middle of
nowhere if you give me 30 peanuts that
doesn't i mean it doesn't
what the [ __ ] but like you're gonna like
it because you have no other options
yeah it's true right it's like you're in
the forest and they're like do you like
it you're like yeah i guess because
there's just trees out there like so you
have to eat it yeah no i no i won't do
it i'm sure it's good but part of that
is like you go through the whole journey
so you think it's better than it is yeah
i don't know if you understand this as
as a woman as much as like we understand
as men like trying to get laid yeah is
so much investment that by the time you
do it you're like oh my god this was
worth it but you traveled into the
forest for five hours right you did all
this thing you know what i'm saying yeah
i know what you're saying boom so we
just just serve it if you get it if you
give it
and it's good right away then it's good
when i don't want it yeah and i still
eat it yeah it's good the [ __ ]
palovanin what is it called
i didn't want it
but then i ate it so it must be good
[Music]
[Music]
ain't the right way just the wrong way
[Music]